with each episode wandavision keeps
revealing new and more interesting
layers to the strange new reality to
find out what's hidden in the basement
keep watching for easter eggs you missed
in one division
one division's seventh episode breaking
the fourth wall brings us to the late
aughts early 2000s in terms of sitcom
references
wanda vision agnes and even darcy
participate in talking head segments in
which they speak directly to the
audience
mirroring the mockumentary stylings of
sitcoms like modern family the office
and parks and recreation
while the style used in episode 7 feels
most like modern family this isn't where
the intro comes from
with its flashes of things you'd expect
to find in a workplace like computer
screens
calendars and the i love wanda coffee
mug plus the derivative theme music it
feels a lot more like the intro to the
office
speaking of office comedies just before
the theme starts wanda tries to laugh
off the bizarre things happening in her
home with it's probably just a case of
the mondays
that's not a reference to the office but
rather a reference to the 1999 comedy
office space
uh oh sounds like somebody's got a case
of the mundus
the opening few minutes of episode 7
also hide one more easter egg
as wanda themed objects appear one by
one a license plate with wanda has the
numbers 12
28 22 those numbers are a reference to
stan lee's birth date of december 28
1922 although the late comic book icon
won't be making any more cameos in
future mcu projects the subtle shout out
makes it clear that lee is gone but
definitely not forgotten
in episode 6 we got to see billy in a
more comic book accurate costume while
pietro gives tommy an outfit that looks
like a smaller version of his own
along with an embarrassing hair makeover
in the following episode both twins get
to looking more like their counterparts
in the source material
breaking the fourth wall doesn't show
the brothers in their costumes but the
color scheme of their clothing does
reflect those of their comic book
costumes
the green and white of tommy's outfit
look a lot more like what he wears as
the young superhero speed
who knows maybe before wandavision
closes its curtains we'll finally see
both brothers and full-blown superhero
costumes as wicked and speed
and if that happens could a young
avengers movie or tv series be far
behind
when wanda gets her breakfast she's
understandably freaked out about her
milk's container transforming a few
times
at one point it becomes a carton with a
picture of a missing child on the back
though we can't make out the child's
face
putting the pictures of missing children
on milk cartons became customary in the
mid-80s so it's interesting to remember
that the one division episode dealing
with the 80s
episode 5 on a very special episode also
happens to be the same episode in which
vision points out that westview's
children are missing
wanda's cereal is interesting as well
first the brand's mascot is a cartoon
clown
and at the end of the previous episode
wanda's expanding hex radius changes the
sword agents into circus clowns
second there's the name sugar snaps it's
impossible to see or hear the word snap
in an mcu production without thinking of
the most infamous snap of all
the one thanos makes to kill half the
universe
as a result of wanda's swiftly expanding
hex radius at the end of episode six
unlike most of the sword agents who are
turned into clowns agent monty is
changed into the circus strongman
it's unlikely that monty has been made
into any kind of superhero but at the
same time when we see a guy in a comic
book tv show and a colorful tight outfit
with a big ass on his belt there's a
good chance that means something when
you combine the s with the blue and
yellow color scheme there are a couple
of different superheroes this could be
referencing
and both of them are super strong one
possibility is the mutant hero strong
guy
when he first joins the new version of
x-factor a strong guy like the rest of
the team wears a blue and yellow uniform
another possibility and a more fitting
one is the sentry like monty's getup
century's original outfit is yellow and
blue and it includes an s on the belt
also while he isn't introduced until
2000s the century number one
it's revealed the hero has been around
since the early days of marvel but the
entire world has forgotten about him
including the sentry himself just as
monty has forgotten who he is
understandably because of reports that
elizabeth olsen's wanda maximoff will be
an important part of the upcoming doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
fans have been theorizing that
wandavision would have something to do
with marvel's vast multiverse one of the
most overt signs we receive in the story
itself
is the commercial in episode vii while
the same man and woman who regularly
appear in wanda vision's faux
commercials weren't around in episode
six
they return in breaking the fourth wall
for an ad that mimics antidepressant
commercials the brand name of the
medication is nexus
a word that has two meanings in marvel
comics both of which relate to the
multiverse
there is marvel's nexus of all realities
which in the prime universe of the
comics exists in the florida everglades
and is guarded by the monstrous man
thing
as the name implies the nexus is a
gateway to marvel's other realities
and then there's wanda herself in the
comics wanda is the nexus being of the
prime marvel reality
as a nexus being wanda reflects her
reality's defining characteristics and
can alter the flow of the future
in the 1998-99 miniseries avengers
forever we learn the powerful immortus
knows wanda is a nexus being
and fears the possibility of her having
children even more powerful than herself
he manipulates events to pair vision and
wanda off as a couple
in the futile hope that wanda's coupling
with an android could never produce
offspring in episode 4 of wandavision we
hear echoes from 2019's captain marvel
as monica is resurrected during the blip
we hear those voices and more again in
episode 7 as monica forces her way
through the hex barrier
and this time it seems clear monica is
hearing them as well we hear the young
monika talking with her late mother
about helping carol danvers we hear nick
fury tell her that she can only follow
the adult heroes as she can learn to
glow like her aunt carol
and we know in the comments she does
glow we also hear different people like
dr harley and jimmy wu
speaking about the death of monica's
mother and of course we hear a refrain
of this line
your mom's lucky when they were handing
out kids they gave her the toughest one
lieutenant trouble he remembered
it's those words that give monica the
strength to push the rest of the way
through the barrier
piercing the hex barrier gives monica
superpowers though it isn't clear
exactly what those powers mean we see
her eyes glow blue
several times and she recovers so
quickly from wanda's assault toward the
end of episode 7 that even wanda is
shocked
in the comics monica is quietly one of
the most powerful heroes in marvel
she's had a number of aliases the most
recent being spectrum
and after she's bombarded with energy
from another dimension she gains the
ability to transform into any form of
energy at will
she's also had another alias that's been
hinted on screen before
photon just like monica's mother's call
sign in the mcu
by the end of breaking the fourth wall a
lot of fan's suspicions that agnes might
be more than a friendly neighbor seem to
have been confirmed
wanda's own suspicions are sparked when
agnes leads her into her home and wanda
notices the twins are nowhere to be seen
she then sees a large loud insect on the
window shade she asks agnes where the
boys are
and agnes answers that they're probably
just playing in the basement
wanda goes down to the basement to look
for them and we get the episode's
biggest reveal
this all unfolds like a tribute to the
silence of the lambs
toward the end of that film the hero
clarice starling believes she's just
doing a routine interview about the
first victim of notorious serial killer
buffalo bill
she's speaking to a man who now lives
where the person she wants to interview
used to live
she's already suspicious of his manner
and some of the things she sees in his
house
but when she notices a large exotic moth
something the killer leaves behind in
his victims throats that seals the deal
she pulls her gun on him and he runs to
the basement where they have their final
showdown
when wanda and agnes confront each other
in agnes basement we learn agnes isn't
agnes
she's the witch agatha harkness we then
get a montage of moments throughout the
series when it's revealed agatha was
manipulating events
it isn't clear however exactly what
agatha is after
harkness isn't a villain in the comics
in fact at different times harkness has
been wanda's ally and even a mentor
while not really a superhero in the
traditional sense she has surfaced every
now and then to aid superheroes during
different mystical crises
so while it's finally confirmed that
agnes is agatha we still don't know why
she's there
it also isn't clear just what she means
when she says it was her all along did
she manipulate wanda into creating
westview or did wanda do it on her own
and agnes has taken advantage of the
situation
just before agatha reveals herself in
the basement wanda notices what appears
to be a very serious looking tone
shimmering with crimson energy
we're not exactly sure what this is
though it could be the darkhold
the darkhold is probably the most
infamous magic tome in the history of
marvel comics
sought after by the likes of doctor
strange and even the vampire king count
dracula himself
the thing is we've already seen the dark
hole in the mcu in both agents of shield
and runaways
and it didn't look like this but on the
other hand it isn't completely clear
exactly what canonical weight a lot of
the marvel tv series have in the mcu
whatever it is when we see agatha use
magic it's accompanied by purple energy
the energy coming out of the book on the
other hand is more red like wanda's
also the design of the book's cover
features two sets of adjoined rings
kind of like twins and wanda's boys are
nowhere to be seen whatever the book is
whether it's the dark gold or something
else it could be acting as the twins
prison
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite wand division moments are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one